remember Sam Brinton Sam Brinton is a
controversial Joe Biden appointee he's
in charge of nuclear waste at the
department of energy and he's the bald
guy with the mustache who is not only a
sexually deviant sort of person
which I don't I don't want to you know
spread rumors or tell Tales out of
school or gossip about anybody but this
is not some secret with Sam Britain he's
made it a big part of his public Persona
he photographs himself wearing all sorts
of weird costumes leading grown men
around on leashes and the men are
dressed up like little puppies he gives
lectures and conferences on all this
kind of weird sexually deviant stuff he
wears dresses and high heels and
lipstick and he's just he's he's pretty
out there well he he was accused a
couple of weeks ago of stealing a
woman's luggage at an airport
and he initially denied it but then he
kind of came out and he said he did it
but he was just tired he didn't mean to
and well now another arrest warrant has
been issued for Sam Brinton for a second
alleged theft at an airport
felony arrest warrant has been issued
for Brenton for Grand Larceny with a
value between 1200 and 5 000 for
allegedly stealing luggage from Harry
Reid international airport so the first
time it didn't take place in Nevada it
took place in Minnesota he flew into
Minneapolis with American Airlines and
he traveled without a checked bag
so it shows you he had no reason to be
at the baggage claim after the flight
and then authorities called him that
same day and asked him if he took
anything that didn't belong to him and
he said no not that I know of and later
he said okay yeah maybe you know look if
I took the wrong bag I'm happy to return
it but this was really weird he said
that the other person's clothes whose
bag it was were not in the bag he said
I don't have any clothes for another
individual
that was my clothes when I opened the
bag but obviously it wasn't it was this
other woman's bag and and apparently on
the security footage you could tell he
he took her tag off of the bag and put
it into his pocket and and so then he
said no it's maybe it's this other one's
bag but my clothes were in it so it's
really you got to ask yourself what is
this guy do
did he steal her clothing did he why did
he did he want her clothing did he did
he just want to steal the bag then he
took this other bag here and and again
according to the footage they didn't
initially couldn't identify him even
though he was wearing this gay pride
nuclear shirt so it was apparently like
a rainbow nuclear reactor or something
like that on the shirt they couldn't
make him out who he was until the the
first news story came up and then they
said wait a second I think that's the
same guy there and apparently he was
exhibiting all this kind of odd behavior
he uh let's see here we are he he was he
he went to the Carousel and took a bag
off and then kind of looked around
suspiciously and put the bag back on and
then you know a little bit later he took
the bag off again looked around
suspiciously so
uh we we have an article here at Daily
wire it says police disclose how they
caught alleged Biden Administration
luggage Thief Sam Brinton and uh
this is a quote from investigators in
Las Vegas they say
Brinton demonstrated several signs of
abnormal behavior
and it goes on to say while taking the
victim's luggage which accused suspects
typically give off
I think you could have stopped at the
first part of that sentence
Brinton demonstrated several signs of
abnormal behavior gee you don't say the
man with the mustache who wears lipstick
he's got totally shaved at where's
stiletto heels mini skirts leads grown
men around in leather costumes on a
leash he he was behaving in a bit of an
eccentric and abnormal way gosh you
don't say you know it's always the ones
you most expect
people like to think it's always the
ones you least expect no no often it's
the ones you most expect
because our perception and our faculties
of Reason are actually pretty good
guides to things and in fact Prejudice
prejudgment looking at a situation and
just quickly having a gut reaction is
not all the time but a lot of the time a
pretty good guide to things this is why
Edmund Burke the conservative
philosopher you know great conservative
philosopher uh so valued Prejudice
because we we don't have a time to in
every single situation in our lives come
up with a perfectly rationalist kind of
explanation and treaty and argument for
what we're about to do we just kind of
go on our gut and we go on hunches and
we we refer to the wisdom of the ages
and we defer to tradition into the past
and we we can trust our gut all right
and that obviously would be the case
with this guy and this guy
Sam Brenton is obviously deeply troubled
and should not be handling anything
involving the America's nuclear program
and should seek a lot of counseling and
maybe should be in a padded cell I don't
know but he certainly should not be in a
position of authority and I I have a
great deal of sympathy for him because I
look at a guy like Sam Brinton who
is so troubled and I think
what if earlier on in his life
someone anyone had just told him no
now we live in a culture where if a
five-year-old comes to school and says
hey hey I'm a girl today they say well
Johnny I guess we're gonna have to get
you on hormone therapy yeah you do that
or what if earlier on in this life when
when this guy was exhibiting abnormal
deviant Behavior
any adult just said hey don't do that
that's wrong if you do that kind of
deviant Behavior that's going to lead
you to more deviant behavior and then
you're going to have a bad life and
you're gonna have all sorts of problems
so don't do that actually you should
look it's a crazy world it's very
diverse we're very eccentric but best as
you can be normal
just be normal I keep coming back to
this theme on the show because I think
it's a pretty good guide for politics
and I think that a lot of the
conservative
political programs should come down to
these two words be normal it's okay to
be normal the left likes to suppress
normality and disparage normality and
and likes to subvert everything and
likes to elevate the abnormal and the
transgressive above all the good normal
stuff but it's okay just be normal guys
it's okay and if people had done that
earlier on in this guy's life maybe he
wouldn't end up as a cross-dressing
puppy fetishist baggage Thief stealing
women's jewelry and clothing at the
airport maybe maybe he would have gotten
take taken the off ramp at some point
down that highway to bizarre
transgressive behavior you look at the
Biden Administration I mean it's filled
with all this kind of bizarre imagery
and often occult symbolism there's that
other guy who was the deputy monkeypox
Czar for Biden who wears overt satanic
symbols where is that the leather
harness and the pentagram and takes and
he too now this isn't secret I'm not
divulging his private sins the guy takes
glossy photos of it puts it out there
into the world the rest of the show
continues now it is music Monday
my producers have they promised me a a
song that requires my uh
hip-hop pop music media Mogul
perspective you know me I'm Wonder Mike
I've come to say hello to the black the
white the red and around the purple and
yellow but first we've got to head on
over to the member block if you are not
a member click the link in the
description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]
all right